i would spoke too soon kim kardashian is
not holding back when it comes to paris
hilton's cooking skills on the aeris new
netflix series
cooking with paris that's hot on tuesday
netflix dropped the trailer for the six
episode series premiering on august 4th
that will feature several celebrity
guests
including the 40 year old kkw beauty
founder who seems a little 50 50 while
tasting a mysterious meal
wait i would spoke too soon and we can't
really blame kim considering paris asked
her this question before making their
meal
what's a tong kim's critiques aside
there is no shortage of the hotel
heiress having confidence in the kitchen
i love cooking your feathers and
everything
i'm a natural
[Music]
but that doesn't mean she doesn't have
her fair share of mishaps
including this moment flipping burgers
with comedian nikki glazer
using her diamond-encrusted spatula oh
no
i burned the diamonds off yeah
definitely and although paris loves
cooking
she isn't afraid to admit she isn't an
expert which is exactly what she did
alongside guest demi lovato you guys
watching at home
we did this wrong so do it the opposite
way for this part
the title of kitchen enthusiasts is just
another addition to paris's growing
fashion beauty and musical empire
paris you have always been ahead of the
curve what's the next thing
look down the road open the crystal ball
tell us what's coming up next
i think what's next especially just
in the whole influencer world i think
that the new
influencer is the activist and i'm
seeing a lot of that right now this new
generation that really cares about the
planet
they care about making a difference and
really fighting for causes
and i find that to be just
so commendable and i really applaud them
and i'm impressed by it
and i don't know i just see this whole
shift right now
and it's very impressive and i have some
future projects coming up so you'll see
and one of the future projects she has
coming up is a wedding
in february et confirmed that the mogul
is engaged to her fiance
entrepreneur carter ream i just i love
how he is
in september paris told et that she
definitely sees herself having a family
sooner rather than later yes i was never
really
open to a relationship because i wasn't
ready to open my heart
just because of what i had been through
so i never
let anyone fully in until now and
now i am just so excited for that next
step and
to get married and have babies and
just finally be hap as happy as i
always wished cheers to paris cooking
many tasty and delicious meals with her
future husband
hopefully without any kitchen
catastrophes
paris pasta did you study this
beforehand
what is zest lemon what's a tong what is
a tomatillo
no okay